this is a production of cornell
university
um mostly what i work on is grapefruit
stock so we're going to talk a little
bit about grapefruit stocks because i'm
contractually obligated
to speak about that and then we're going
to leave the
bounds of real science and uh chase
speculation
and innuendo and other things which i
find amusing
and hopefully you'll find amusing or at
least confusing
it's something to the whites the most
important people
in our research program on grapefruit
stocks are the people who
actually conduct the work and who take
care of the plants
in the greenhouse and our nematode
colony every single day of the year
even on federal holidays and on weekends
and when the power goes out
and that's deb johnston and jason plate
so
many thanks to them for conducting most
of the experiments which i have the
honor to be here
today with you to talk about and they
have actually
been the ones who extracted the seeds
grew them and in most of the cases
collected the data
which i am going to present so many
thanks to deb and jason
and if there are some cases where we
have older data i usually explain
who it was that helped us to generate
that data as well
of course thanks to the department of
horticulture
and to neil for the invitation and to
the different
organizations and institutions who have
supported the research
which we're going to describe often in
the context of
grape root stock improvement and then
these other projects which
turned out to be interesting and somehow
we hope
uh tangentially related to root stock
development and breathing
in the long run most of our funding
comes from the usda
agricultural research service which is
my employer and usda ars
has a research team and two research
units
at the experiment station in geneva
all right this is a grape root many
times magnified
and it is swollen in many spots and has
small red dots on it those red dots
which to the naked eye are about the
size
of a typewritten period are egg masses
of root not nematodes melloida guyanese
species
these happen to be melodigna aranaria
the other common species of melodione
nematodes
make similar symptoms and have a similar
egg mass
found on the surface of the root these
have been stained
with esn y so you can see them easily
with the naked eye or maybe not so
easily since we spent a lot of time
looking at pounds and pounds and pounds
of roots to find those egg masses
we are interested in finding resistance
against root knot nematodes
why are root not nematodes a problem in
new york well they're a problem in new
york for certain crops
not really a problem for grape although
you would certainly find root on
nematodes and vineyards
in the united states most of the
vineyards are in the san joaquin valley
between sacramento and bakersfield and
by far root not nematode is the most
important problem
in those vineyards so by area in the
united states
we have more area of vineyard where root
not nematode is the chief problem
than any other soil pest even phylloxera
so phylloxera is an insect which feeds
on grapevine roots and
can also feed on leaves and that's a
serious pest that can actually kill
grapevines but
by area we have much more territory
where rudinot nematode
is the key pest it's not napa or sonoma
or the east side of cuba lake which make
wonderful fine wines
it tends to be more like popular
consumer areas where
grapes are grown and wine is made so if
you enjoy
wines which retail for under five
dollars a bottle probably you would be
more concerned about root not nematode
than for the sixty to seventy dollar
bottles of wine they're all part of
viticulture analogy
but the root not nematode prone areas
have usually received
less attention certainly in the popular
press and by the white consumers
but for viticultural purposes they
represent the
ungrafted and real potential for
resolving a soil pest problem through
the introduction of root stocks
there are nematode resistant root stocks
which are used and as you might expect
from generations of using nematode
resistant root stocks
we have in fact found a root stock
resistant nematode
gene for gene selection just like
antibiotic resistant bacteria
usda released two root stock varieties
about 40 years ago
freedom and harmony and after a few
generations of using those root stocks
in one site
you usually select for a virulent
population of nematode just as you might
expect
because there's nothing else for the
nematodes to feed on so the one or two
individuals which are capable of
breaking that resistance
then reproduce the root dot nematodes
which are important on grape
root stocks are all obligate mitotic
parcenogenates
which means that not only do they not
need to have sex and want to reproduce
they can't have sex and so if you have
one individual which is virulent on a
rootstock it can just lay lots and lots
of eggs
about 2 000 per female and that allows
you to have a big blow up in the
population of nematodes
we don't think that they actually spread
from location to location
virulent populations probably aren't
spreading around the san joaquin valley
they're probably a rising de novo
wherever you are from the existing root
not nematode population
so that project developing identifying
nematode resistance against the virulent
nematode populations has
been our main focus for the last 12
years i started in the fall of
99 identifying sources of superior
resistance
deploying them into improved root stock
varieties and evaluating those varieties
in a place where the nematodes are
important and finally releasing them
to the nurseries and the viticultural
community
here are some of our advanced selections
and new rootstock varieties
matador and kingfisher are two nematode
resistant root stocks which were
selected in geneva
and were released in 2010
as new varieties we also have minotaur
which is a full sibling
of matador these root stocks were all
selected because they provide protection
against those
virulent nematode populations which are
capable of feeding on and damaging
freedom and harmony so if you like they
are the next generation of fruit stocks
do we think that they are more durable
than the previous generation of
rootstocks or are we just
entering into an arms race with a
nematode well
probably we're entering into an arms
race with the nematode
if i play my cards right i can just arms
raise the nematodes until the end of my
career
and i'll retire and leave that to the
next folks
and they can solve the problem once and
for all or possibly
we can find ways to pyramid nematode
resistance
or find other durable sorts of nematode
resistance
that are less amenable to that selection
for virulent populations so
this is a story we've heard in other
sorts of plant breeding
we have a variable pathogen which
responds to the deployment of resistance
and then the plant breeders can respond
to the response
and this can go on when we are selecting
for
new varieties of rootstock we're chiefly
concerned
with resistance against pests and
diseases which
attack and damage the grapevine roots
that's the chief reason that we use
rootstocks in viticulture
we can easily propagate nearly any
variety from cuttings
the rootstock provides us with
protection against the pests
and the pathogens which are living in
the soil there also
is an aspect of effect of the rootstock
on the growth and development of the
scion
so we want to be aware of how the scion
and the rootstock interact
in selecting matador and minotaur and
kingfisher
we selected the rootstocks in the trial
which gave us an improved
yield efficiency over freedom in other
words
those vines make for the same amount of
shoot growth
or branches or wood they make more fruit
so there's an increased efficiency which
we believe is related to the root stock
we've seen that with other root stocks
been reported by other groups as well
so we've selected the root stocks which
are resistant to nematodes
and which give us an improved yield
efficiency what the nurseries have
expressed
great pleasure about is the fact that
the vines are a little bit smaller that
means that they get to sell more vines
per acre
and since they sell vines on a per piece
basis not on a per acre basis
then everyone's happy the grower gets
more yield efficiency per plant the
nursery sells more plants
and we have resistance against the
nematodes as well this material
on the right is on my right is an
example of one of our selections
still in trial and you may be looking at
this if you're working on brood stocks
and say
nes videona what's that well it's a wild
grape species that's native to
eastern mexico and we have been using
the north american including mexican
wild species as sources of nematode
resistance
in developing new root stocks root
stocks need to be easily
propagated from dormant cuttings that
characteristic mostly comes from
the species vitus riparia and
viceroypestres and so those species are
found in
nearly all of our rootstock hybrids it
turns out that there's a lot of nematode
resistance in wild grape species
and accessions so having the repository
here in geneva
and also a davis is a great source of
new nematode resistance genes and
alleles
just why there's so much nematode
resistance in wild grapes is anybody's
guess there aren't a lot of nematodes in
the forests
where wild grapevines live so maybe it's
accidental or it's resistance against
something else
it doesn't really matter but it's
interesting question from an ecological
perspective
so as we're selecting it needs to be
something which will propagate the
nurseries
and we have had many selections
unfortunately tossed out because the
nurseries call me up and they say
this stuff doesn't propagate you're not
getting your plants i don't care how
resistant it is
if it can't be propagated from a dormant
cutting it's not a grapevine rootstock
in looking at nematode resistance and
finding materials from the wild we would
like to characterize
how that resistance is inherited and how
different sources of nematode resistance
relate to one another
generally speaking grapevine is more or
less a diploid we'll talk
more about that and so if you have any
given
uh locus for nematode resistance usually
you have up to two choices
of alleles which you can put at that
particular site
however if you have multiple loci for
nematode resistance that increases our
chances of being able to pyramid
multiple sources
into one variety or selection
and therefore we might be able to have a
more durable plant
if we have multiple loci they're
conditioning nematode resistance
so what we know for sure is that vitus
mustang ansys in the upper left
and vitus cortifolia in the upper right
represent loci which are
different for their nematode resistance
compared to the locus which is found
in freedom and harmony so we know that
those
loci independently segregate in fact the
alleles that we've deployed from
mustangsis and vitus corefolia provide
superior protection
to that found in harmony and in freedom
so we know that not only is it a
different locus
that also provides protection against a
broader population of nematodes
so now we have root stocks which are
pyramiding which have
both and different sources of nematode
resistance into individual plants
and we've confirmed that the
old-fashioned bad way by test crossing
because we don't yet have effective
molecular markers
which can diagnose that so we're now
engaged
working with bruce reich and others on
the vitus gem project to help identify
the molecular markers which are
predictive of nematode resistance which
will facilitate not only breeding but
also pyramiding
multiple sources of resistance we have
multiple sources of the
single dominant gene resistance like we
see from freedom from harmony
from vice mustang ansys from bias
corefolia there's another source from
espana and also from an established
rufo tomentosa type and those all behave
very nicely as single dominant
alleles coming from one locus
we also have sorts of nematode
resistance which do not behave
cleanly as a single dominant allele but
still provide a great
degree of nematode resistance against
those virulent populations
including virus by formus in the lower
left which is a
tropical and subtropical species our
accessions come
from the lowlands of east central mexico
and we'll talk more about device by
formis
later on the talk because they're a
tropical species
they have a lot of tropical species
characteristics like they don't ever
want to go to sleep
and try to keep their leaves all the
time which might be an advantage
or disadvantage comparing where you live
and vinus rotundfolia
the muscadine grape native to the
southeastern united states
and long recognized as being highly
resistant
against many grapevine meaning bunch
grape
pests and pathogens also highly
resistant to root not nematode
what we have found is that crosses with
vitus return to folia
tend to be less cold hardy than either
of their parents this again has been
reported by other research groups
but when you find something which is
winter killing at 35 degrees fahrenheit
not only can you not grow it in the
finger lakes you actually can't grow it
in fresno
or even bakersfield so those materials
were tossed out of the program
despite the fact that they were highly
resistant to rental nematodes
we are interested not only in root not
nematode resistance but also in
protection against other sorts of pests
and pathogens phylloxera is one which i
mentioned that's an
insect related to an aphid which can
feed on and damage the grapevine roots
a group at the gyvelerhof
viticulture and grape breeding program
and
also at geisenheim in germany has been
working on characterizing
the hypersensitive resistance against
phylloxera which comes from the
rootstock burner
burner is a hybrid which has by a
scenario as one of its parents and it
has a hypersensitive resistance as the
phylloxera tries to feed
either on the roots or on the leaves
there's just a necrotic response and the
phylloxera fails to establish a feeding
site
is that better than the resistance and
tolerance that we have in the rootstocks
which we're currently using like 3309 or
st george
which have a mixture of resistance and
tolerance
um it's not clear that it's either
better or worse
we certainly don't have enough long-term
field trials we know that in nature in
north america
some species have hypersensitive
resistance and some species have
this resistance and tolerance
combination and they seem to coexist in
nature
it's hard for me to believe that if you
had exclusively root stocks
in an area where there were no wild
grapes to provide a refuge that the
phylloxera would put up with a
hypersensitive resistance gene for very
long
because there'd be a huge incentive for
the phylloxera to overcome it just as we
saw in the root not nematodes
but we are continuing to work with
burner as a source of phlox resistance
that's the vine on the left and trying
to to
introduce that hypersensitive pheloto
resistance
into our other grapevine rootstock
backgrounds
in combination with other sources of
resistance and tolerance
okay what else are we doing with with
grape vines
if you're interested in studying root
knot nematode resistance
somewhere along line you're going to
need some grape roots
if you plant an individual grape seed in
about a month it'll be
four or five inches tall and have enough
roots you can put some
infectious juvenile nematodes on it and
then six or eight weeks later you can
wash the roots off and look for the
symptoms and signs
of the nematode infection stain the
roots and look for those galls
and the egg masses and determine that a
plant a given plant is
resistant or tolerant or somewhere along
the special this the
spectrum between resistant and
susceptible
suppose you want to have a replicated
measure of
resistance in other words maybe i spaced
out i forgot to inoculate one seedling
and it looks resistant just because
again we forgot to inoculate it well the
answer is we have to replicate
but what a hassle it is to take an
individual seedling
plant it out into the vineyard wait for
a couple of years three years four years
until you have enough
cuttings that you can then take cuttings
from that plant in the vineyard
root them and they root at different
rates so we have plants of different
sizes and root systems
wouldn't it be easier if we could do
this much more quickly on something
small
so now we are screening individual
rooted leaves
a grapevine ordinarily does not make
adventitious buds
so you can take a mature fully expanded
leaf
root it in a little bark sponge just as
we've done here
and plant that in a pot and it will live
more or less happily
for months it doesn't grow a bit except
in the roots
so we take this individual root leaf put
in a little pot
now we can easily make replications from
a seedling grown plant
in the span of a few months because the
individual seedling has many leaves
we can then make replications the little
plants the root leaves
don't need to be pruned because they
just don't grow
eventually we wash the soil off the
roots and we have the same type of
nematode response
as we would expect to see from the
individual seedling or from a root
cutting
it never grows any more shoots it just
stays as an adorable little leaf it's a
little peculiar when you see them in the
greenhouse
but we've allowed ourselves a way to get
a replicated
observation on a seedling which has
never gone out to the vineyard
and that's useful for genetic mapping
purposes
for doing molecular marker development
or any other project in which we'd like
to accelerate
replicated nematode testing in most
cases for breeding it's enough that we
can make a first pass
through the seedlings because we're
going to go back later and evaluate them
for
rooting ability grafting ability double
check the nematode resistance
in a case of mapping population we'd
like to just look at the hematoma
resistance
and do that as quickly as possible so
that's where the rude leaves come in
other things that we've been working on
when we are out with
grape root stocks anybody want to hazard
a guess what the difference is between
these two leaves
not everyone at once though
okay here's a qualifier how about the
one on the left looks
toothier do you believe that
maybe question quit maybe questionable
do they look different
how about that not very different well
they're different enough the leaf on the
left is thicker
it has spikier teeth as far as i'm
concerned the
petiole or sinus or the petiole connects
to the blade is a slightly different
shape
and if you conduct flow cytometry on the
plants
on which these leaves were growing you
will find out that the plant on the left
is an auto tetraploid of the plant on
the right
and we have generated auto tetraploids
by treating
the mature plants growing in the
greenhouse with surf land herbicide
active ingredient a rhizolene over a
span of 30 to 35 days
and arizona acts as a plant microtubule
poison we know that it is an herbicide
and in fact we're usually losing between
a third and a half of the plants
after we spray them over the course of a
month with an herbicide
but a few survive and we can select
those plants which have
the apparent tetraploid phenotype
they're
very slow growing and they have a
thicker leaf with spike your
marginal teeth and grow that as its own
plant
why would you do such a thing auto
tetraploid grape root stocks
are de-vigorating compared to the
diploid progenitor
so if you like a particular grapefruit
stock but it's just too vigorous for
your particular application
well hang on we're going to make you an
auto tetraploid of that
the pioneering work in this area was
done in japan
and their root stock studies demonstrate
you can
use the auto tetraploid in the same
conditions for the same pest
and soil conditions as you would use the
diploid progenitor
but that is devigrating so we are using
this approach for root stocks which have
particular pest
and disease resistance but which have a
problem with excess vigor
in this case it's o3916 and trying to
develop a lower bigger selection or
clone of those already known root stocks
the best evidence suggests that if we
were then to make crosses
amongst the auto tetraploids we would
get aloe tetraploids and those have much
much higher bigger
so perhaps down the line we'll have
higher vigor root stocks
out of this project as well for the
openers we're trying to find
lower vigor versions since often that is
what growers are complaining about is
not enough low vigor root stocks across
a spectrum of different pest and disease
resistances
it's a little bit of a dark art so
people have generated
tetraploids and grape root stocks using
all sorts of techniques and
the one thing which unifies them is that
they never adequately describe what
they're doing
either how much or what or for how long
they did
and we're not going to do it either so
that's as much information as you're
going to get
i have them uh a few more things about
spiky leaves and uh slipping beyond
the realm of rootstocks just to touch
the leaf on the right is a little
spikier on the teeth
than on the one on the left this guy
spends too much time in the vineyard
looking at leaves if he's
concerned about what's spiky or not this
is a variety called chamberson
which is a grape that's used to make red
table wines it's probably a little bit
in the finger lakes it usually likes a
longer
ripening season so you see it more in
pennsylvania and in the midwest this
particular picture was taken in illinois
it's a wine grape and like nearly all of
our wine grapes chamberson ought to be
perfect flowered however growers in the
midwest
have complained that they find fruitless
vines
in their chambers and plantings and the
vines are fruitless
because they are stamina or male
flowered
where did those come from well we don't
know exactly where they come from
we believe that they really are a bud
sport of chamberson they have the
same microsatellite fingerprint as
chamberson
and yet they have male flowers so we've
collected
several of these from vineyards in the
midwest where the growers said yeah take
it away we don't need it
they grow very vigorously because the
vines don't carry any crop
they are pollen fertile but they don't
produce any fruit so we're working with
the
group at guy vallerhoff in germany who
has
been characterizing the sex locus in
grapevine
and what we have now is essentially a
bud sport which has gone from being
perfect flowered
to stamina flowered and they're going to
be using that as a
a tool and characterizing the sex locus
previously they've been able to
distinguish between female and not
female
and now we have a an additional genetic
tool to help distinguish between
perfect and male or perfect in stamina
which are the two categories of
non-female
in grapevine nearly all of our plant
material
for cultivated wine grapes or table
grapes is in fact perfect flowered but
when you work on root stocks
you can fool around with the other
categories of flower sex
to your advantage or confusion okay
now we talked about nematode resistance
we've talked about other aspects of root
stocks
and while we're working on root stocks
because we are
not as concerned about fruit quality
until we graft it and then we come
interested in fruit quality we can
tinker with the way that grapevines are
put together
and hopefully we can take with that to
our advantage so
some things about grapevines which if
you work on other plants
i think it's important for background
first of all the tendrils
in a grapevine are the lateral meristem
that's derived from an inflorescence
so picture a tendril as a bunch of
grapes or clustered grapes
with all the grapes taken off of it we
know that that organ is used for
climbing and for support in nature and
also in the vineyard
and the function of that organ is
interesting to us but it's kind of
peripheral
that's a totally different story for
this point for now i want you to
remember that those are interrelated
structures
and that either using chemicals or using
genetics
we know that those structures can be
turned or converted
one into another into the other that's
part of the sex change
story which was in the title of my talk
how does this
organ or this lateral meristem which is
ostensibly
a sexual organ how does it get assigned
to become
a vegetative organ and i know you're
asking this question
why would anybody care about that
well we'll talk more about why we care
about that this is a grapevine shoot
and many grapevine varieties have a
shoot comes out in the spring looks very
much like this
grapevines do not have separate
vegetative and reproductive buds
or vegetative and reproductive shoots
there's one shoot and it's both
vegetative and reproductive
on the same shoe typically on a shoot
there's a transition so that the lateral
mirror stems
closer to the base of the chute are
reproductive that is they are
inflorescences or clusters
and they develop into bunches and then
there's a unidirectional shift
usually unidirectional as you go out the
chute and
as you go towards the apical meristem
you're more likely to find
tendrils which are a vegetative lateral
meristem
so exactly where that transition point
occurs
and how that is determined is the topic
of some additional research
something else to notice is that what is
usually considered to be
a defining characteristic of grapevines
of the genus vitus
is that every time there's a leaf there
is an axillary bud
we tend to think of this as really key
if you
hang around with the 5 or 6 vitacy
botanists in north america
then we can all agree that if it's a if
it's vitus
a true grapevine and there's an axillary
position
and there's a leaf there's gonna be a
bud in there in fact
even the cotyledons of a vine have
axillary buds
if you grow the grapevine from seed you
can notice those little axillary buds
that's not true for all members of the
vitaceae so other species or other
genera have
patterns of axillary bud production and
that's part of the phylotactic
differences
between grapevines and those other
species of those other genera
and that becomes important if you're
propagating ornamental sisters for
example
you need to leave enough buds probably
in by cuttings you need to leave enough
buds so that you're actually going to
have branches otherwise you'll just get
a rooted cutting which doesn't have any
growing points from it
okay so more about this later but now
you know how the
wild type situation looks like from a
rootstock perspective
i'm very interested in the number of
clusters per shoot because the vine is
usually going to try to ripen the fruit
before it does anything else that's a
reproductive strategy
it's a plant which propagates by seed
and it needs to get those seeds out
there
into the world in order to propagate
it's not going to propagate itself by
cuttings
we are going to propagate it by cuttings
but the vine doesn't know that
this is a selection from our rootstock
breeding program it is highly resistant
to root not nematodes
and it also produces seven eight or even
up to nine clusters per shoot
that's a lot of fruit in fact it's too
much fruit
look what do you care for a rootstock
vine that produces too much fruit
well i'll tell you this vine doesn't
produce any wood to speak of
if you grew it in the nursery it would
spend all its time trying to make fruit
and ripening that fruit and eight or
nine clusters per shoot
are too many the vine manages to make it
through the winter
and it manages to direct all that fruit
but it doesn't put a lot of energy into
making new shoots
and if you're a rootstock breeder or if
you run a nursery you need to have
cuttings
that's what you're selling that's what
makes new plants so
this plant doesn't make enough cuttings
but
that could mean that we were just a
little bit too heavy on the accelerator
i mean
if you know what that transition point
is we've pushed it too far
now we've got eight or nine nodes which
have
fertile lateral meristems reproductive
lateral meristems
and maybe we could find that same
trigger and ease off on it
so that our average number of clusters
per shoot is
less than one or maybe it's zero can
this switch
used to be used bidirectionally it's not
true of all switches and plant
development
but we think it might be true with these
mostly when we're looking at grapevines
the number of clusters per shoot
is fewer than five and in the case of
most of our wine grape varieties it's
between one and three
so seeing something which has eight or
nine is excessively the other direction
the other day i got an email about
someone who was complaining because they
had 14 15 clusters per shoot
and the material was flowering and they
were harvesting at the same time so
yes that's a serious problem when you're
trying to mechanize harvest
another thing to notice about grapevine
shoots is that there's a pattern
in the distribution of the lateral
meristems nearly all species
have two nodes with a lateral meristem
followed by a node without like the
picture on the top
but one species various labrusca
usually produces a lateral meristem and
that could be a an inflorescence
or it could be a tendril at every node
so
most species have a pattern of two with
and then a skip
and one species has continuous
production
at all the nodes in the mature
vine why is that important to us
well that depends how important are
tenders to you
if you do your own pruning you probably
hate tendrils more than any other part
of the grapevine
because they are hanging onto the
trellis wire and they prevent you from
clearing the brush out
i do all my own pruning so i'm
incredibly frustrated
with the production of tendrils and from
a rootstock perspective they don't serve
any function
we know that in nature grapevines need
tendrils to climb onto trees
and for support but they probably have
very little role in modern viticulture
we've built them a nice trellis
or we're growing our rootstock vines on
the ground from a nursery
production standpoint and we would like
them to not
cling to each other we'd like them to
come cleanly out of the
vineyard row when we pull those cuttings
we did an experiment where we looked at
a series of populations which were
crosses of parents with different
numbers of
tendrils per shoot so you can picture at
one end of the spectrum
you have perfectly two nodes and then
a skip uh at the other end end of the
spectrum
it's perfectly every node with a tendril
in between those are lots of different
intermediate phenotypes like
five nodes in a row uh with a tendril or
an inflorescence followed by one skip
which is somewhere intermediate between
those two in this case we made a cross
using the same male parent
which is vitus labrusca so all the
positions
on that vine either with a cluster or
the tendril and both of the parents in
this case have the same wild-type
phenotype
two positions with followed by one skip
this is to illustrate that there's a
difference between the parents
1613c and 187g which have the same
phenotype but they breed differently so
when we look at the seedlings
and looking at the number of tendrils in
the first
12 alternate phylotaxi nodes we'll talk
more about that in a bit
then we see that there are different
ratios if you're interested in
increasing the number of tendrils
you should definitely make crosses with
16 13 because you've got lots and lots
and lots of tendrils
in the offspring jillian may be a little
bit concerned about this because she
knows that last summer when she was the
chalice research scholar she did a lot
of counting of shoots
with tendrils and it turns out that
there are some relationships that
jillian
doesn't even know about yet because we
just did the data analysis last week
about how the position of the tendrils
and the number of tendrils on the chute
relates to the transition in phylotaxi
on individual seedling i'm a rootstock
breeder so i want to have the fewest
number of tendrils possible
which direction do we go well in this
example you would definitely pick 187g
because it has a much lower average
tender count
in its offspring we might have
compelling reasons to go the other
direction
for sure we'd like to know how that's
controlled how does the plant make that
pattern
not just the organ itself but how is
actually making the pattern
many of you will recognize a picture of
the dwarf grapevine
the pixie vine which was released by
usda ars
in 2007. it's a cooperative
release with the university of
california davis and developed using
tissue culture
from the l1 outside cell layer of
pinamonye
so the pixie vine has a naturally
occurring gibberellic acid and sensitive
mutation
and it's a gibberellic acid mutation
that reduces the sensitivity of the
planted ga
so as you would expect it has shorter
internodes
grapevine seeds need gibralic acid in
order to germinate
the dwarf plants from pixi or pixi
grapevine crosses
require an additional dose of
gibberellic acid at five times the
ordinary dose of ga
in order to induce germination of the
dwarf plants additionally in grapevine
the gibberellic acid signal helps
determine the assignment of that lateral
meristem
so the more ga signal is received in the
plant
the less likely that lateral meristem is
to become inflorescence
these plants are of lower sensitivity to
ga
that means they're less likely to
receive that signal and so the lateral
meristems
preferentially become inflorescences
well that's handy now we have a plant
which is
more or less continuously flowering in
the greenhouse and it's a dwarf
vine and we can use that in genetics
experiments or physiology experiments
pathology etc
this is an example of the three classes
of seedlings you would expect to see
from self-pollinated pixy vine that's a
perfect flower plant
we have wild type seedlings on the left
you can see the first
tendril emerging opposite of leaf the
heterozygote vine in the middle the
heterozygote is blooming these pictures
are taken about 95 days after we plant
the seeds
the first flower is actually open on
this plant at this point you can't see
it because it's hiding in there in those
dwarf internodes and finally the
homozygous plant
on the right homozygous plants quite
frankly are tricky to deal with
and we've usually just tossed them out
because they're
so small and slow growing but you can
actually cultivate those and use those
in crossing as well
it's a semi-dominant gene so if you are
making crosses with the pixie line or
other headers like our dwarfs
you should expect on average to receive
back half dwarf fines
flowering from seed in about 90 to 100
days
we're very close to having a grapevine
which will produce
two generations per year and
since the last time i was giving a talk
in this room which included
the pixie vine we've made some
improvements and passed a lot of
germplasm
this is rudy eibach who is one of the
great breeders and geneticists
at guy vollerhof in germany and you can
see that he has his own
tiny forest of dwarf grapevines which
were grown from seeds which we sent him
from geneva
why would they be interested in dwarf
grapevines they would like to develop
dwarf grapevine populations which have
the sort of wine
grape characteristics that they like and
also are carrying the
disease resistance alleles which they
have been carefully mapping
and cloning and developing molecular
markers for ethical heart breeding
program
so they see the dwarf grape as a way to
accelerate their breeding
in addition to accelerating breeding you
might just use it as a way for doing
genetic
genetics experiments because the plant
becomes sexually mature in such a short
period of time
and in a small pot as we can see then
there might be some characteristics that
you're not interested enough
in to dedicate vineyard space and all
that time
training and pruning those vines just to
get them up in flower
but you might be interested in doing it
on a benchtop or perhaps
as a year-long student project where
they do need care and maintenance but
it can be conducted over the course of
one or two semesters
rather than the course of the entire
graduate student's time at cornell
we now have white fruited dwarf
vines and we have pistol flowered dwarf
vines
the pistol at floured ones are much
easier for making crosses on
as you can imagine because they don't
need to be emasculated and yet they're
still passing on that
dwarfing characteristic inherited as a
semi-dominant gene
so we haven't released any of that new
plant material yet but for us it's very
useful
because now we have something which is
white fruited we have materials
which are pistol-flowered and we'll be
continuing developing
the standard genetic tools different
colors different flower types different
backgrounds
in the dwarf type and making those
available for
researchers okay quick recap
what's wrong with this picture
okay what's this it's supposed to be a
tendril
but low it has a shoe tip on it so why
did that happen
here's another case this one should have
been an inflorescence
but it's got a shoe tip growing out of
it so here again is the main shoe
here's the inflorescence here's where
the influorescence attaches back
to the main chute and that inflorescence
actually has a shoot tip growing out of
it
this can be an example of virus
infection but this happens so
consistently on vines which are
in fact not infected with virus that we
think there's something else going on we
think that it is
involved with genetics this is a shoot
from a population that
segregates for that lateral meristem
conversion
and you can see the leaves on what
should have been a tendril
this one has a full on shoot tip
and it's producing lots and lots more
shoots
than it ought to that's probably the
opposite direction
i mean i'm making viticulture worse than
better with this kind of plant material
but what we think is happening is that
one of the determinants to
shoot development is turned on or it's
left on in these plants
even to the extent that the lateral
meristems which should be
determinate are becoming indeterminate
vegetative meristems they're becoming
lateral meristems that just keep growing
and making new shoots
interestingly enough if you look at the
shoots on these plants
that grow from these indeterminate
lateral meristems they themselves have
ordinary tendrils
so it's something associated with the
primary chute axis
of that plant as far as we know it seems
to segregate
as a as an incompletely dominant
characteristic at least in some genetic
backgrounds and this is again a
characteristic of a trait that we're
going to be
crossing into our dwarf finds though so
that we can study it through multiple
generations
but not take up lots of vineyard space
we don't quite know what makes it
operate
another example of strange things from
the vineyard and it looks like an
ordinary grape shoot
but when we look up more closely we see
that it is in fact
missing axillary buds 100 percent of the
positions across from the inflorescences
on this plant are missing axillary buds
and on related plants we see a lower
incidence of the missing axillary buds
but always in that same position so
there's something competitive about the
inflorescence
and the axillary blood production now we
see that
also in other species in the vitacy but
not reported extensively and certainly
we have no idea the genetic control
within the grapevine itself why is that
important well
now we have the potential to have less
branching
in the fruiting zone as a rootstock
breeder i'm gonna get rid of all the
axillary buds and just make long
straight shoots i'll strip off the
tendrils and the flowers too while we're
at it
but even from a wine rake perspective
you might like to see missing axillary
buds
now and again we probably have too many
buds on the grapevine we cut off most of
them thrown on the ground
anyway maybe we could genetically remove
some of them in advance
this is not a grapevine this is
amphilopsis glandulosa it's another
member of the grapevine family
and the genus amphilopsis is usually
distinguished from vitus they're fairly
close to really genera
one of the characteristics is that
amphilapsis has
no true tendril production all of the
lateral
meristems are producing in fluorescences
if you have a
porcelain berry or pepper vine these are
some common names for
amphilopsis you can go out to those
vines in the fall in september or if we
have a nice october
they'll still be producing little
inflorescences so they have
mature fully colored up fruit mature
fruit with mature seeds
and all throughout the season they're
producing fluorescences bad if we wanted
to eat them
i wouldn't recommend eating them anyway
but bad if you wanted to eat them and
harvest them mechanically because you
get the whole mix of
of fruit but interesting from an
ecological perspective say well
grapevines don't do that
but we have some grapevines that do that
this is the material from the repository
which is continuously producing
inflorescences in preference of tendrils
so just like the pixie vine
which produced inflorescences instead of
tendrils because it has gibberell gas
and mutation
but this is a wild grape from the woods
and it
has wild type growth it has not dwarf
stems
it does not require additional
gibberellic acid in order to germinate
the seeds
but it is producing inflorescences at
all of those lateral meristem
positions this one happens to be stamina
flower the pistol at floored ones
do the same thing so it's an
ampilopsis-like grapevine
and we are interested in this material
because of the potential for using that
in developing a different direction in
precocious flowering
grapevines one which is not dwarf but
just easily flowering
so we made some crosses with the wild
material
and then grew seedlings from second
generation crosses
in our greenhouse in geneva and
grapevines are usually more fertile
on the secondary lateral buds at any
given
axle than they are the primary
branches of that axle so we grew the
plants up
top them took out the primary laterals
and let the secondaries grow
and in fact we see a segregation for
flowering
as low as the 10th node so this seedling
started flowering
on a branch at the 10th node and again
that can be accomplished in about 90 to
100 days
in our greenhouse this particular
seedling it happens to be stainless
flour we get the same thing in perfect
flour individuals
what we haven't recovered yet is the
perfect floured
continuous flowering type just like the
wild material in other words
every position with a perfect flowered
in fluorescence just like we see in
epilepsy
here's some flower clusters and the
perfect flowered ones
make little clusters in the greenhouse
just as we've described
finally a little bit of discussion about
the transition
on a grapevine seedling between the
different types of phylotaxi
here is a grapevine seedling and it's
growing a little pot in the greenhouse
grapevine seedling when it comes out of
the seed first it has a
spiral phylotaxi and does not produce
any
lateral meristems and then at some point
and we're not 100 sure what the trigger
is truly there's both a genetic and
environmental component
the grapevine starts making tendrils and
it has an alternate phylotaxi
which is the mature phylotaxi of that
plant so
below between the yellow bars is the
juvenile spiral phylotaxi and then it
makes this
unidirectional shift which can be
reproduced by vegetative propagation
to making tendrils we know that tendrils
are in fact a sexual structure
even though they are derived to be
vegetative and climbing
here again is a case where we have a
population that
segregates for the position of the first
tendril so
that's the point at which we have
shifted from the spiral phylotaxi
to the alternate phylo taxi and there's
a big difference between these two
populations
why would you care about something like
this i i'm
sure you're wondering in fact it turns
out
and this is based on the research that
jillian and i did last summer
the point of transition from spiral
phylotaxi to alternate phylotexy
is closely related to the number of
tendrils
that you would expect to see on the
plant that is growing
once it starts making tendrils in other
words
the fewer the nodes before it starts to
make
tendrils the more tendrils that you're
going to have when it finally starts
making them
that indicates that we probably have a
way to predict
the final number of tendrils on the
plant even though the plants are very
very small
if we're talking about breeding new
varieties which are going to be
used for experimental purposes flowering
in the greenhouse like the pictures we
just saw derived from those tropical
plants
we want them to start making that
transition point as early as possible
because they don't seem to flower if
they have spiral phylotaxi
they don't start doing that until you
get into the alternate phylotactic mode
so we'd like that to happen as low as
node 7 or maybe node 5
rather than having to wait till node 9
or above that
every node that we can eliminate from
the requirement before we get to
alternate file taxi means we're that
much closer to getting a
rapid continuously flying grapevine i
keep talking about this until
wednesday i'm going to pause now catch
my breath and ask geneva if there are
any questions
geneva has no questions geneva can you
hear us
yes have you ever seen any
seedlings that have tendons and no
one or two of the copperlines never have
you
no uh i think the lowest i've seen
martin i have to go back through my data
is node four
it certainly varies from population and
population
okay
i guess that's it for now okay i
promised you file a taxi
question from ithaca
yeah uh go back to earlier what you said
that
always surprised me you apparently you
can root grapes really easily you can
get a
petiole to root yes um yet growers
always want to use
hardwood cuttings why not i mean you
threw out a whole bunch of potentially
useful
genotypes for nematode resistance right
and you could probably get them through
it with software cuttings
yes uh so so so why so why don't we
yeah um at least part of it has to do
with the tradition of the
of the way that grafting has been done
so let me
jump to the far end of that story for
muscadine grapes
they're very difficult to root from
norman cuttings
and historically they're all done by
layering wow that's expensive
but with mispropagation it's 100
switched
to propagation by uh softwood cuttings
and and it's a standard and it's no
problem
if you are going to make a plant from a
a
hardwood cutting and grafted or a
dormant
sorry a green growing bench craft you
can take a dormant cutting and a dormant
bud
graft those together this may and plant
it in the vineyard this june
no waiting it's ready to go if you were
to take a
soft wood cutting you would ordinarily
have to grow it for
many months or maybe even a full year
before you had a dorm plant that you
could graft
because even though you can do soft wood
grafting or green grafting
it's very expensive compared to the
bench crafting with dormant buds
so it has much more to do with the
structure of the nursery industry
and you know one growing season
yep yep you you theory
theoretically you would get there um and
and i
i recognize how there there might be
cost savings but
nobody does that at any sort of scale
i agree it might have been useful some
of it we've kept to use on breeding
but um i would say that we are on a
nursery driven demand for easily
propagated plant material
it costs them the same to take to take
the cutting and make the graft whether
or not they get a plant out of it or not
so they prefer to have 100 rooting from
all their derma cuttings
right or wrong that's the system we have
yeah back to the end of your talk
for rudolph resistance are there
different mechanisms
are they pretty similar across the range
that you have what are the mechanisms
so we know for sure that there are
at least three different points at which
the nematode
resistance seems to be implemented or
affected
one is that there's a penetration
resistance that nematodes don't actually
make into the root
another is that there's nematode
penetration to the root and it migrates
to the root but they fail to establish a
feeding site
and also we know that in some cases
there's establishment of a feeding site
so they've gone on the route that
they've moved around they've established
but they don't reproduce so since
resistance is defined as the
impact on reproduction any three of
those would uh likely to be
uh included in the reproduction and we
see
all sorts of those segregating in our
populations
chiefly different forms
some combination of those three
mechanisms no well we're not looking at
a mechanistic approach what we're
looking at is different individual genes
to provide
protection and so we're looking at the
resistance
meaning we just look at the reproduction
of the adult female nematode
and when we're trying to pyramid sources
we look at ones which
prohibit reproduction in a sense we're
summarizing
all the different types of resistance uh
which could be implanted so we don't
actually have a mechanistic
approach to that and is there any
relationship with the
root not nematode resistance mechanisms
and
zip nema or is there any sort of really
broad spectrum
nematode feeding deterrent good
mechanism good question
um ziffany mandex is a dagger nematode
there are other dagger nematode
species which feed on grape roots we
don't think that there's any mechanistic
relationship
between those because there are some
materials which are
highly resistant to ziphenium index
nematodes
such as o3916 rootstock but they're
highly susceptible to
root knot and others which are very root
not nematode resistant
and have susceptibility to xiphonium
index so as far as we know
there's no correlation or plyotropy
with regard to those nematode
resistances and we're not working with
other nematode species but
work from other groups andy walker's at
uc davis seems to indicate that those
are
independently controlled you can find
resistance other nematodes but doesn't
necessarily relate to root non-empty
resistance
did you find you were mentioning earlier
that
you could influence the amount of top
growth that you get
on the vine by the rootstock correct do
you find
also an influence more directly on
quality of the of the wine that is
produced from that
from that a direct influence no but
indirectly through the king growth and
stuff
correct so definitely root stocks
influence the
growth and development of the canopy and
that
influence on the growth and development
that can't be influences all sorts of
things
water relation to the plant light
environment of the canopy
and those in turn influence fruit
composition
and wine quality but as if you had two
identical
canopies with different root stocks it
would be very unusual to expect a
difference in the fruit composition
other than what comes from the
canopy architecture
good thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu